[Music]
our series school matters features
extended stories and investigations on
education and today we're looking at a
lawsuit winding its way through the
federal appeals process that questions
whether access to literacy is a
constitutional right a federal judge in
Michigan recently ruled it wasn't when
he dismissed a 2016 case that case
claimed students in some of Detroit's
lowest performing schools were denied
access to literacy due to poor
management discrimination and
underfunding CBS this morning Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller shows us how
students and teachers are fighting for
the rights of all students Michelle good
morning good morning for years the
Detroit Public Schools were under
control of emergency managers who were
trying to lift the district out of debt
but this case is drawing national
attention because of its wide-ranging
implications possibly leading to federal
changes to the education system there is
no escaping the alarming fact that
performance in many Detroit Public
Schools is sagging I often have
conversations with my student they would
say you know we felt like people don't
care about us we have a book where Bill
Clinton is the president and it was
actually the same book I you when I was
in middle school no although now we
located to another Detroit school
Rodney fresh used to teach at one of the
schools named in a class-action lawsuit
which accuses the state of systemic
persistent and deliberate failure to
deliver instruction and tools essential
for access to literacy which serve
almost exclusively low-income children
of color it wasn't a fight one or two
students how many students are we
talking 40 to 50 soon I read anywhere
between a 1st grade and sixth grade
level and the 10th or 12th grade you
welcome this lawsuit yes
superintendent of Detroit Public Schools
nikolai bt who was appointed just last
year is attempting an overhaul you
really believe that children in this
district were used as political pawns
walking into a system
that was not run appropriately gives me
evidence that decisions were made not in
the best interest of children but you've
gone one step farther you said that the
policies in place were racist I have and
they are because that because the
governance system that existed in
Detroit would never ever have been
acceptable in any suburban district in
this country anywhere government figures
suggests Detroit children are falling
behind only 5% of the city's fourth
grade students can read at or above a
proficient level for Detroit's eighth
graders that number rises to only 7% how
does this happen I mean students are
saying that they were denied their basic
constitutional rights a student in
kindergarten for example wasn't even
exposed to kindergarten standards so
we're setting children out for failure
Jamari a hall says he was one of those
children's set up to fail one of the
original members of the plaintiff class
coming from Detroit they always say 9
times out of 10 you're barely gonna
graduate high school you're gonna end up
into things that nature so I just don't
want to be a statistic home now lives in
Tallahassee attending Community College
in hopes of getting into Florida A&M
University
just how far behind are you it makes me
almost feel like I'm dumb sometimes I'm
not as smart as I need to be but yeah I
know it's not my fault I know it's just
the school system that came from do you
know what reading level you're reading
at now I'm probably just getting to
about junior senior in high school so
when you think about the possibilities
out there do you feel cheated yes always
like 10 steps behind like we're always
trying to catch up I mean if this case
goes all the way to the Supreme Court
and it's struck down or it's not even
heard what then at least we tried it's
at the end of the day that's all you can
do you say that I tried we reached out
to both the Michigan Governor Rick
Snyder and the state's Board of
Education for an interview request and
common
they told us they could not comment on
pending litigation ja ten steps behind
always trying to catch up
Thank You Michelle